[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 60,18 l'essentiel de
l'actualité locale et régionale tout de
suite les titres de ce mercredi 11
juillet les yvelines ont chaviré hier
soir la france est en finale de la coupe
du monde de football des scènes de
liesse dans tout le département est
forcément à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
1300 personnes ont assisté à la victoire
des bleus face à la belgique au palais
des sports d'el en cours nous étions sur
place est les terrains qui les abritent
était menacée de ventre et des privés à
benne et thiverval grignon de gisements
de fossiles sont désormais protégés l
état a pris récemment un arrêté pour
préserver ces sites découvert au 18e
siècle dans les gisements et des restes
de mollusques de 45 millions d'années et
puis quarante ans qu'il n'était pas
organisée à versa et le bal des pompiers
revient dans la cité royale l'événement
se tient ce vendredi à partir de 20
heures
elle nous en parlons avec le commandant
stéphane goubert et l'adjudant chef
olivier morello de la caserne de
versailles la folie a envahi le pays
chez douze ans après la france est de
nouveau en finale de la coupe du monde
de football la qualification des bleus
face à la belgique a été suivie par plus
de 19 millions de téléspectateurs
tricolore à elancourt 1300 personnes ont
vibré à la retransmission de la
rencontre organisée au palais des sports
de la ville la fête s'est poursuivie
tard dans la nuit ambiance avec mélanie
poquet et mickaël millero ce mardi 10
juillet les yvelines au vécu une nuit de
liesse aux quatre coins du département
des milliers de supporters sont sortis
dans la rue pour fêter la qualification
de la france pour la finale de la coupe
du monde
quelques heures plus tôt au palais des
sports d'elancourt les gradins avaient
pris des allures de mini stade de france
avant le match contre la belgique
les 1300 supporters présents dans cette
fan zone ont vibré sur chacune des
actions du match
à la mi-temps la belgique et la france
le tra lise 0 à 0 un peu inquiète en
même temps dans nos chansons font
les six heures qui vont percer la
défense et être au moins un butin ce
supporteur français était entendu six
minutes après la reprise samuel umtiti
marque 1 0 pour la france
le palais des sports chavire dans le
bonheur l'atmosphère devient de plus en
plus tendue au fil des minutes et enfin
c'est la délivrance la france est en
finale de la coupe du monde pour la
troisième fois de son histoire
on a tremblé mais je pense qu'on n'y
avait qu on est que dès le départ et on
a vu que dépendent et marquer le premier
but je pense qu'on pouvait même en voir
en prennent en mettre un deuxième
on la ramène des scènes de joie qui se
sont poursuivies tout au long de la nuit
dans les rues des longs cours avec un
concert de klaxons de plusieurs heures
il ne fait que les yvelinois espère
vivre à nouveau ce dimanche 15 juillet
avec une victoire lors de la finale et
la qualification de l'équipe de france
pour la finale de ce mondial a forcément
suscité beaucoup de réactions sur les
réseaux sociaux notamment à des
réactions des hommes politiques
yvelinois sur twitter le président du
sénat gérard larcher a salué un match
magnifique et le travail des joueurs
ainsi que celui de didier deschamps et
son staff
toute la france est avec vous
assure-t-il bravo les bleus a tweeté
pierre b dit le président du conseil
départemental des yvelines voix en
l'équipe de france un groupe rassemblé
uni complémentaires et donc efficace
d'autres ont joué la carte de l'humour
vous le voyez avec ce tweet de l'ancien
candidat à la présidentielle benoît
hamon qui a donc twitté à propos du
buteur d'hier soir face à la belgique
samuel umtiti le maire de bois d'arcy
philippe benassaya lui propose une
nouvelle version de la devise nationale
liberté égalité bat p autre bonne
nouvelle a forcément fait moins de bruit
de gisements de fossiles vont être
sauvegardés étudié depuis le xviiie
siècle la benne et thiverval grignon
il était menacé par la vente de terrains
à des privés litas l'état a finalement
pris un arrêté pour les protéger c'est
une première en france est des gisements
qui abritait des mollusques vieux de 45
millions d'années regardez ce reportage
de mélanie poké et camille lambert ici
sur le site de grignon nous avons les
témoins de l'arrivée de la mer à environ
dans le sud du bassin de paris à environ
46 millions d'années c'est ce que l'on
peut observer dans cette carrière le
griot les témoins d'une époque où la mer
arrivait jusqu'à paris ce sont ces
fossiles de mollusques ou ressent
nautile et autres animaux marins
aujourd'hui présents des régions
tropicales plus de 800 espèces
différentes réunies dans une zone de
plus de 33 hectares à grignon on va
pouvoir n'est trouvée par euros par
millions à partir du moment où tamise
vous regarde le solde suffit de regarder
le sol sol est pétri de coquillages qui
sont d'une conservation
exceptionnel si on se place à l'échelle
mondiale et bien on a une faune qui est
quasiment parmi les plus riches du monde
au niveau de la paléo biodiversité un
gisement étudié depuis le xviiie siècle
pour préserver ce trésor historique et
scientifique
l'état a pris un arrêté de protection du
patrimoine géologique pour cette zone et
pour une autre de 9 ha ha ben une
première en france
ce site qui était qui était au seinde
agroparistech donc un domaine de l'état
on a entendu que ce site talent être mis
en vente
donc un privé donc ceci compense est
protégé depuis plus dedeux faim depuis
qu'on connaît en fait l'existence du
patrimoine géologique était menacée
puisque salle est vendu à un privé grâce
à l'action de la direction régionale de
l'environnement et de l'énergie et à la
commission régionale du patrimoine
géologique les gisements sont désormais
hors de danger
les scientifiques du monde entier
pourront continuer à percer tous leurs
secrets
il n'en existe qu'une poignée en france
une crypto station vient d'ouvrir ses
portes à versailles ce comptoir permet
d'acheter ou de vendre des devises un
peu particulière ça s'appelle des crypto
monnaie leur particularité elles
fonctionnent grâce aux réseaux
informatiques et ne peuvent être
falsifiée lé détail dans ce sujet daury
dire 11 et outils nirhy lanto j'étais
pas bien si
[Musique]
premier achat de bitcoin pour cette
cliente
ouverte fin juin à versailles la crypto
station est un comptoir permettant
d'acheter ou de vendre plus de 300
crypto monnaie des monnaies virtuelles
qui n'existent que sur internet
la plus emblématique et le bitcoin ces
deux monnaies qui a été vraiment créé
suite à la crise financière de 2009
manque de confiance en les institutions
les bacon aujourd'hui et décentralisé
c'est à dire qu'il n'est régi par aucun
état souverain
aucune société aucune personne
aujourd'hui il est possible de payer en
bitcoin sur plusieurs sites internet ou
encore dans certains cafés parisiens
présents sur tous les continents sa
valeur est déterminé par l'offre et la
demande et fluctuent tous les jours lors
de notre tournage il valait un peu plus
de 6700 dollars alors d'aujourd'hui
c'est un marché qui se porte très bien
nous sommes actuellement je crois à 300
milliards de capitalisation boursière
pour tout les crypto monnaie et nous
pensons nous écrite aux stations que ça
va aller bien au dessus tout ça est que
nous si tout se passe bien cette amené à
remplacer toutes les applications que
vous connaissez aujourd'hui normalement
cette technologie devrait distribuer
tous ces secteurs dans les dix ans
je trouve vraiment bien d'avoir des
personnes physiques en face parce qu
interagir avec son ordinateur
et quand on comprend pas certaines
choses on n'ose pas franchir le pas
alors qu'ici bas comme vous avez pu le
voir il ya des gens qu'on franchit pas
tout de suite en fait pour acquérir ou
vendre des bitcoins chez crypto station
il faut être majeur et présenter une
pièce d'identité
il s'est tenu pour la dernière fois le
13 juillet 1978
quarante ans après le bal des pompiers
revient à versailles il se déroule ce
vendredi 13 juillet c'est à partir de 20
heures à la caserne de versailles pour
en parler avec moi en plateau deux
invités le commandant stéphane goubert
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le chef de
centre du le chef du centre de secours
principal de versailles vous êtes
également avec nous en plateau
l'adjudant chef olivier morello bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le président de
l'amicale des sapeurs-pompiers de
versailles qui est donc à l'origine de
ce retour il manque à la cité royale ce
bal des pompiers
il manquait depuis 40 ans et des très
attendu et très demandés par la
population versaillaise commandant
boubet quand l'adjudant chef est venu
vous voir avec ce projet c'est normal de
donner son aval de faire renaître ce bal
des pompiers
alors là dedans chef est venu me voir il
ya presque trois ans maintenant pour
commencer à relancer l'idée d'un bal
organisé par les sapeurs-pompiers de
versailles en collaboration avec la
mairie de versailles est un crime bien
partenaires sur cet événement samia tes
réflexions j'étais plutôt favorable mais
j'étais surtout très décidés à ce que
tous seront organisées de façon très
rigoureuse pour pouvoir bien accueillir
l'ensemble des versaillais et des
habitants des communes qui nous entoure
donc c'est avec un grand plaisir que
j'ai validé cette idée parce que je sais
qu'on peut compter dans notre centre de
secours sur 130 hommes et femmes prêts à
faire tout pour faire plaisir la
population ce soir-là telle importance
peut avoir un tel événement pour nous de
recevoir la population versaillaise et
aux alentours dans notre notre caserne
dans un contexte différent que le
quotidien de nos interventions et
surtout un moment de deux traditions et
de fait qui manquait
à versailles ce qui a rendu possible le
retour de cet événement le commandant
boubée en parlait c'était le fait que la
mairie de versailles s'associe également
à ce projet la mairie de versailles
avait co organisatrice de l'événement 1
on est bien sûr une démarche de bal
populaire et du coup quand la dhimma
dynamique festive et politique est en
route
rien de sart est un art est le projet
c'est ce sera donc le 13 juillet au soir
ce bal des pompiers c'est une bonne
occasion de fêter finalement le 14
juillet d'autant il faut le rappeler qui
aura pas de feu d'artifice à à
versailles donc c'est une occasion de
faire la fête à versailles oui alors il
y avait déjà le 13 juillet un bal
organisé par les services de la mairie
de versailles ont souhaité s'associer
parce que vous les pompiers sont pas en
dehors de la ville il contient en
particulier à versailles ont la chance
d'avoir un son discours très actif
juste à côté de la mairie donc la
géographie en plus au-delà des absences
relation qu'on a au quotidien nous
rapprochait de l'équipe municipale qui
effectivement cette année a fait le
choix de raison de sécurité de ne pas
organiser de proposer en tout cas tonnes
de feux d'artifice ce soir là donc sans
le remplacer on propose autre chose
on propose un bel événement populaire
pour accueillir beaucoup de monde dans
notre centre de secours vous parler de
l'aspect sécuritaire justement ce qui
rend possible cet événement c'est que ça
se fasse dans un endroit fermé la
sécurité sera sera assuré ce soir là
pour le bal des pompiers
nous allons accueillir les gens dans
notre centre de secours dans la cour qui
est devant et dans l'espace très
agréable qui est juste derrière la
mairie de versailles
c'est effectivement un peu plus facile
et sécurisé donc
c'est bien la mairie qui participe la
sécurisation avec une société privée qui
nous accompagne toute cette soirée là
c'est effectivement un peu plus simple
dans cet endroit et avec des conditions
d'organisation qui nous ont été imposées
d'ailleurs la classe d'anne la caserne
sera organisée pour l'événement pas de
camion qui seront présents sur place ils
seront garés un peu plus basse et ça
parce qu'il faut le rappeler les
pompiers travaillent ce soir là il ya ce
bal mais bien sûr il n'est pas les
pompiers ne s'arrêtent pas les pompiers
c'est bien 24 heures sur 24 c'est bien
toute l'année et ce soir là aussi et
peut-être en particulier parce que ce
seront des soirs qui peuvent être très
occupée pour nous en moyenne les
pompiers de versailles c'est parce que
trente interventions par jour
donc évidemment cette nuit là on aura de
l'intervention ils vont s'organiser pour
bien sûr ans pour le même service à la
population que n'importe quel autre soir
de l'année olivier morello revenons à la
fête elle va durer de 20h jusqu'à 3
heures du matin il ya des groupes de
musique et dj qui sont au programme quel
est le programme justement de cette
foire est alors deux ambiances
différentes tout au long de la soirée à
une première partie de soirée bal
populaire traditionnel très familial
avec
une troupe de chanteurs facile hume
d'accord avec plusieurs chanteurs et
chanteuses sur scène et une deuxième
partie de soirée un peu plus rythmée à
partir de minuit avec un art un jeune
artiste qui en est ainsi en train de
monter vraiment de manière très
importante et qu'on aura l'occasion de
revoir très prochainement je pense sur
des sur des plateaux de celle ci les
landes funk a d'ailleurs déjà fait la
première partie david guetta qui est un
dj un peu plus excusez moi exactement et
y si dans son parcours actuel ont enfin
gagné beaucoup de deux premières places
de différents festivals
donc voilà une belle surprise pour pour
ce bal que la présence de nick stevenson
avec nous et la présence de la banda
soit l'os capitaux ce qui serait là un
qui sera très mobiles dans la dans la
soirée et qui pourrait même être aussi
beaucoup d'ambiance à un entre-deux
tours entre la demi finale et la finale
de foot qui j'en suis persuadé
du coup serait encore plus festive pour
l'événement précisons c'est important
que les bénéfices de cette soirée seront
reversés à l'eau dpe des pc l'oeuvre des
pupilles orphelins des sapeurs pompiers
oui tout à fait un traditionnel mans
comme comme le font nos collègues de
poissy et montigny est aussi rambouillet
donc pour le bal du 13 et 14 juillet les
bénéfices de cette soirée bien
évidemment seront versés à l'eau des
pays bas on y est très attaché une
question plus pratique pour terminer
comment fait-on pour participer à ce bal
des pompiers à versailles soit vous
pouvez les sur deux sur la page facebook
du bal et vous inscrire pour les pré
ventes l'asie affiche actuellement il
reste encore quelques places
sinon vous donne rendez vous le soir
même à partir de 20 heures et vous
pourrez vous présenter directement à
l'accueil
eh bien merci à vous de commandant
stéphane goubert chef du centre de
secours principal de versailles à
l'adjudant chef olivier morello d'avoir
été avec tôt elle joue en chef que je
rappelle et le président de l'amicale
des sapeurs-pompiers de versailles et ce
bal des pompiers de versailles et donc
au programme vendredi à partir de 20h
plus d'informations sur la page facebook
de l'événement et si vous adorez
l'ambiance populaire des bals des
pompiers vous pourrez peut-être remettre
ça dès le lendemain le 14 juillet jour
de fête nationale les pompiers de
montigny le bretonneux organise
également leur bal le rendez vous était
fixé à 19h30 au centre d'incendié et de
secours de la ville
à l'entrée de 10 euros avec une
consommation et 8 euros si vous prenez
une prévente encore la bonne humeur pour
refermer cette édition à la bergerie
nationale de rambouillet une dizaine
d'enfants à poser bagages détente le
temps d'une semaine
ces jeunes participent à un chantier
bénévole en aidant à restaurer et
préserver le site c'est dans le cadre de
l'opération nationale du ministère de la
culture c'est mon patrimoine
une activité pédagogique qui allie
ateliers manuels et découverte des lieux
nicolas landry et nicolas kirillovitch
comme s'ils étaient de vrais ouvriers
équipés de gants de protection ces
enfants très organisés des places de
lourdes pierres leur objectif réussir à
bâtir avant la pause déjeuner une
spirale aromatiques un peu petit
c'est un coup les plus grosses au mieux
à la fin ils sont au total 12 stagiaires
venus de toute la france a participé à
ce chantier bénévole sur le site de la
bergerie nationale de rambouillet pour
eux les grandes vacances d'été riment
avec préservation du patrimoine
ça doit rester dans l'histoire de france
et bah voila quoi faut entretenir ce
qu'ils ont construit avant ça me fait
découvrir des bâtiments
parce que moi je connais pas trop tous
les bâtiments au monde
les bâtiments ils sont jolis ça fait et
le topix comme kevin de la préhistoire
est con et ça le fait
construite à la fin du xviiie siècle la
bergerie nationale est le lieu idéal
pour apprendre les anciennes techniques
de chantiers comme la maçonnerie ou la
taille de pierre mais aussi pour ces
jeunes apprentis découvrir la vie en
communauté et partager leur
environnement et finalement c'est aussi
le vivre ensemble la vie collective
l'ont fait à manger
hier soir hier après-midi au talent et à
la cueillette sûr qu'il puisse
participer à l'élaboration des repas
qu'on découvre ensemble et légumes qu'on
ait cuisine est en fait finalement
toutes les activités qu'on avait à
l'année elle ni limiter son pouvoir
faire l'expérience chantier en général
pour les enfants les enfants sont en
stage jusqu'à la fin de la semaine pour
entretenir et embellir le patrimoine
rambolitains des chantiers dans toute la
région
sont eux proposer jusqu'à la fin de
l'été le 7-8 journal touche à sa fin
merci de votre fidélité c'est à revoir
sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile tv à 78 à suivre dans
quelques minutes le dernier numéro de la
saison du 7-8 culture présentée par
mélanie poké excellente soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]